well thank you again Beth Neville Beth
tell us a little bit about the
missionary history that runs through so
many generations in your family and also
where you actually spent your early
formative years of life I grew I was
born and grew up in Japan because my
parents were missionaries my father grew
up in China as a child of Presbyterian
missionaries and his father yes his
father also lived in China as a young
young child because his father was a
missionary to China so I would have my
cousins who are missionaries I have some
cousins that are missionaries are 4th
4th generation missionaries presbyterian
and so this is dating back to the 1800s
at least yeah I shouldn't have a date
but I don't was probably the mid 1800s
and do you think that that is part of
the reason why you do some of the good
work that you have been doing for so
many years well I don't like it when
people call me a missionary because my
work is not faith based and I think it's
slightly arrogant for someone to claim
that they're doing God's work and
actually my father thinks the same thing
he sort of has he was in Japan for 20
years and recently said to me what were
we doing there telling people how to
live what to believe and he's sort of he
spent the last 20 years of his life
working with ecumenical relations which
is working with other churches or other
faiths so I i think that i don't i don't
have the the church is not in my work in
that way at all but I I don't even I
don't know if these kinds of values or
sensibilities are bred into one but i
guess the older I get the harder it is
for me to deny that that had something
to do it with what I do now yes now
before we talk about this passion you
had a previous passion that was quite
creative tell us a little bit about that
very jealous
Maxim's Taylor because that's what I
used to do I used to view Taylor yeah
and I've made clothes for tell us who
were Tom Wolfe the writer who's you know
my most famously bespoke customer and
who else and Julian Bond and Dave
Matthews a few things how did they've
Matthews Band yeah the but for summary I
don't know why that happened Tom Wolfe's
sister was married to my husband's aunt
so he was kind of a family connection
that's why that but mostly I made him
bath robes and pajamas I have made two
jackets there's a really really nice
nice shirt I recently you had to alter
it did you or me as I he sent me at no
no he sent me an old smoking jacket that
I made for him it must have been 20
years ago and instead of having a new
one made I'm patching this one taking
the cuffs off and reversing him so that
they won't so they won't see the hole
but I have to put little elbow patches
on what he loves it so much that's what
so great about him he loves his clothes